what the hell is this Gavin Newsome
tackles a kid in a basketball game
really who we dissecting if that's
intentional is that a flagrant
foul oh tried to set the pick oh we know
what that was nice try
governor oh my God he bulldozed that kid
all right little [__] you want to
play big ball yeah yeah okay you want to
go hard in the paint little [__] all
right I'll show you who's winning I am
the governor I own California [__] I
own this
land why is he grabbing the kid like
that he spanked him too yeah what the
hell just choking him out there at the
beginning
yeah you try to [__] you try and guard
me again huh try and guard me again
I'm the governor and they roll over for
the
[Laughter]
cameras he slapped them on the back to
wake him up again from yeah he he's
popping some smelling salts right below
that right there you can you see he's
cracking some smelling
salts what a horrible position to be in
as a political figure seriously that
smile he knows he's [__] remember when
I choked out that Chinese boy at the at
the basketball court and I spanked him
yeah I like the way his ass fell in my
hand you know he walked off the court
and his handler was like why'd you do
that it was an
accident I mean you pretty much did the
worst possible thing you could do in
that scenario they close the door on the
limo Gavin what the [__] what the [__]
man I
know I'm sorry I [__] up yeah big time
look at this
picture how does this look the dude from
the back look pretty bad yeah it looks
bad
right some 20 something in
turn Mr Mr Newsome it looks
terrible I got you okay
man he can't stop he can't stop I got
you made it
worse why won't he let him go Gavin Why
You Gavin why' you say I got you at the
end why did you squeeze him again
why' you why did you I don't know I was
trying to make it like a playful thing
it was [__] weird Gavin why did you
say you got some love handles on you at
the end why did you say that at the very
end that was [__] crazy man why did
you say I'm going to take
you why did you say try that again and
see what
happens Rick Shaw Mike why did you say
that I got you you're never going to see
your parents again
that some old school ball right there
look at this look at the
form he goes for a little spin
move fakes the
trip fakes the trip
oops look at him wrapped around the neck
don't you ever try to set a pick on me
[__] don't you ever try to set a
pick on me you little piece of [__]
you're 8 years old I'll [__] kill you
right here in front of your whole family
you dumb [__] he
yeah I got
you Gavin Dam near near just like did
that thing when the kid stood up and he
tried to hold the part of his pants so
he'd pants him and embarrass him like he
damn near did that so the kiss like H
he'd be like yeah yeah would you ever
[Music]
dare that was a spank I got you I got
you I got you
that kid just has that memory forever
now I know he's Going's he's going to be
in the yearbook kid that got spanked by
[Laughter]
Gavin all he's growing up hey remember
Gavin Newsome came over here and he
spanked the [__] out of
you wow what a guy yeah what a guy dude
can
ball I would love to see for sure I'd
love to see him in Obama face off who
Obama Obama obam obam yeah oh dude I'm
[__] dying damn well we got another
hour man I know I know you excited yeah
um that's why I'm going to have this oh
go [__] Gavin knew some spanking
children oh God you
like retweet quote tweet quote tweet
sick shouldn't have tried to guard him
yeah lay off my Governor lay off my
Governor yeah that's right don't you
ever dare set the pick on
newy Gaby
newie mess with the gav you get
jabed the [__] is this Biden about to
eat a
kid I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm joking
I'm joking I'm
joking what Obie Biden was going to eat
you no that's Gavin Newsome dude that's
Gavin Nome Obie that's Gavin why looking
at you like that bro he was going to
[__] put you in a cauldron why is he
looking why did he make you take your
shoes off before greeting
him he's going to put you in a cauldron
this picture is crazy he's
like you trying to guard me right now
yeah you trying to guard me I'll put up
[__] 30 on your
head you know I don't play on anything
less than a regulation
board no go ahead try give it a shot I
see those three Hocus Pocus witches
ankles what' you say those three Hocus
Pocus witches in the background dude
they're going to put Obie in that
cauldron Kevin new's GNA eat her when
was this what's the
story it was that like a yoga opening
event years ago I when I was living in
San Francisco what is a yoga opening
event I don't remember duh the US Open
for
yoga there's a bunch of [__] moms
head of
yoga all right who can downward dog the
most yeah and now we have not we have
leth from Seattle yeah going into the
downward dog wow look at how down she's
getting the form is unreal you know men
the most downward we've ever
seen
bunch of perverted ass husbands In The
Crowd Oh
God Jesus
Christ do you mean like a was it like a
yoga like was it like a yoga studio yeah
I think I don't really remember because
I was really young and Gavin was just
checking it
out oh what a creep you got the only
picture of him got caught new yoga
studio hey Mr new uh I was just dropp
by I think he was friends with someone
there it was when he was the mayor of
San Francisco oh I don't know that's
crazy that's a this is a crazy
picture
yeah what a what a shot he he's going to
yeah he's looking like he's going to
harvest you for
[Laughter]
adrenochrome that's how his ankle stayed
So
Young Drew all that blood from oie
I live to tell the tale yeah I
know